hi this video is a recording of a talk
that i gave a while back i already
published a version of it on my second
channel but
did you even know i had a second channel
most people don't i thought more people
should see it so i remastered it i
cleaned it up improved the graphics and
yeah this is that enjoy right
hello everyone my name is robert miles i
am usually doing this on youtube i'm not
really used to public speaking
i'm not used to not being able to edit
out my mistakes there may be mistakes
also
i may go too quickly um sorry not sorry
so uh when it comes to ai safety you can
kind of divide it up into four
areas along two axes you've got your
short term
and your long term and you've got
accident risks and misuse risks
and that's kind of a useful way to
divide things up ai safety
covers everything the area that
interests me most
is the long-term accident risks i think
once you have very powerful ai systems
it almost doesn't matter if they're
being used by the right people or the
wrong people or what you're trying to do
with them
the difficulty is in keeping them in
under control at all
so that's what i'm going to be talking
about what is ai safety why is it
important
so i want to start by asking the
question which i think everybody needs
to be asking themselves
what is the most important problem in
your field
take a second to think of it
and why are you not working on that um
for me i think the most important
problem in the field of ai
is ai safety this is the problem
specifically that i'm worried about
that we will sooner or later build an
artificial agent
with general intelligence so i'm going
to go into a bunch of these
terms the first thing is what do i mean
when i say sooner or later
this is a little bit washed out but this
is a graph
of a survey a large survey of ai experts
these are people who published in
major a.i conferences and they were
asked when they thought
we would achieve high-level machine
intelligence which is defined as
an agent which is able to carry out any
tasks humans can
as well as or better than humans and
they say that uh 50 chance of of
having achieved that we we hit that
about 45 years
from 2016. um but then of course we hit
like 10
chance nine years from now so um
it's not immediate but it's happening
this is definitely worth
taking with a pinch of salt because if
you ask the question slightly
differently you get an estimate of 120
years rather than 45
there's a lot of uncertainty in this
area but the point is
it's going to happen as i said sooner or
later because at the end of the day
general intelligence is possible the
brain implements it and the brain is not
magic
sooner or later we'll figure it out so
what do i mean when i say an artificial
agent
well so an agent uh is a term from
uh economics mostly but basically agents
have goals
they choose actions to further their
goals this the simplest expression of
what an agent is
so um the simplest thing that you might
call an agent would be something like a
thermostat
it has a goal which is to have the room
be at a particular temperature
it has actions it can take it can turn
on the heating it could turn on the air
conditioning
it chooses its actions to achieve its
goal of maintaining the room at a steady
temperature
extremely simple agent a more complex
agent might be something like
a chess ai which has a goal of
like if it's playing white it has a goal
of the black king being
in checkmate and it takes actions in the
form of moving pieces on the board in
order to achieve its goal
so you see how this idea of an agent is
a very useful way of thinking about
lots of different intelligence systems
and of course
humans can be modeled as agents as well
this is how it's usually done in
economics
individuals or companies could be
considered to have a goal
of you know maximizing their income or
maximizing their profits and making
decisions
in order to achieve that
so when i'm talking about intelligence
intelligence has a lot of as a term is a
heavily loaded term has a lot of
different
people put their own definitions on it
in this context what i mean when i say
intelligence is just
the thing that lets an agent choose
effective actions it's
whatever it is that's in our brains or
that's in the programming of these
systems
that means that the actions they choose
tend to get them closer to their goals
um and so then you could say that
an agent is more intelligent if it's
more effective at achieving its goals
whatever those goals are
if you have two agents in an environment
with incompatible goals
like let's say the environment is the
chess board and one agent wants
white to win and one agent wants black
to win then
generally the more intelligent agent
will be the one that gets
what it wants the better ai will win the
chess game
um and finally general intelligence this
is where it becomes
uh interesting in my opinion so
generality is the ability to behave
intelligently in a wide range of domains
if you take something like a chess ai
it's extremely narrow it only knows how
to play chess
um and even though you might say that
it's more intelligent than a thermostat
because it's more sophisticated it's
more complicated
it couldn't do the thermostat's job
there's no
position on the chessboard that
corresponds to the room being a good
temperature
there's no move that corresponds to
turning on an air conditioner the chest
ai can only think in terms of chess
it's extremely narrow generality is a
continuous spectrum
um so if you write a program that can
play an atari game
that's very narrow deep mind one of
their early triumphs was
that they made a program that could play
dozens of different atari games single
program that could learn all of these
different games
and so it's more general
because it's able to act across a wider
variety of domains
the most general intelligence that we're
aware of right now
is human beings human beings are
very general we're able to operate
across a very wide range of domains
including and this is important we're
able to learn domains which
evolution did not and could not prepare
us for
um we can for example drive a car an
evolution did not prepare us for that
we invented cars they're very recent um
we can
you know invent rockets and go to the
moon and then we can operate on the moon
which is a completely different
environment
and this is kind of the power of general
intelligence really the power of general
intelligence is
we can build a car we can build a rocket
we can put the car on the rocket take
the car to the moon
drive the car on the moon and there's
nothing
else that can do that yet
um but sooner or later right
so so this is what i'm talking about i'm
talking about
what you might call true ai real ai the
sci-fi stuff
um an agent which has goals
in the real world and is able to
intelligently choose actions in the real
world
to achieve those goals now that sounds
i've said i said what's the biggest
problem this doesn't sound like a
problem right
on the surface of it this sounds like a
solution
you just tell the thing you know cure
cancer or maximize the profits of my
company or whatever
and it takes whatever actions are
necessary in the real world to achieve
that goal
but um it is a problem
so the big problem is this should be
auto playing and it isn't
um the big problem is it's difficult
to choose good goals
um so this this is an ai made by open ai
it's playing a game called coast runners
which is actually a racing game
they trained it on the score which you
probably can't see down here it's
currently a thousand um what the system
learned is that
if it goes around in a circle here and
crashes into everything and catches fire
these little turbo pickups they respawn
at just the right rate
that if it just flings itself around in
a circle it can pick up
the turbo and that gives you a few
points every time you do that
and it turns out that this is a much
better way of getting points
than actually racing around the track
and the important point here is that
this is not unusual this is not open ai
doing anything unusually stupid
this is kind of the default um picking
objectives is surprisingly hard
and you will find that the strategy or
the behavior that
maximizes your objective is probably not
the thing you thought it was
it's probably not what you were aiming
for uh there's loads of examples
actually uh victoria has a great
list on her blog deep safety if there's
like 30 of them
different things going wrong there was
one they had uh
they were trying to teach they were
trying to evolve systems that would run
quickly so they they trained them on the
i'm going to pause this because it's
distracting as hell
where's my mouse yeah pause
pause please um they were training like
agents that were supposed to run so they
simulated them for a particular period
of time and measured
how far their center of mass moved which
seems perfectly sensible
what they found was that they developed
a bunch of these creatures which were
extremely tall and thin with a big mass
on the end
that then fell over because they weren't
simulating them for long enough
the you could go the fastest just by
falling over rather than
actually running that moved your center
of mass the furthest um
there's a lot of these there was a
tetris bot which um
would play reasonably well and then just
when it was about to lose
would pause the game and sit there
indefinitely because it lost
points for losing but didn't lose any
points for just sitting on the pause
screen indefinitely
this is this is like the default of how
these systems behave i have
no memory what my next slide is oh yeah
right so we have problems
specifying even simple goals in simple
environments like atari games or
basic evolutionary algorithms things
like that
when it comes to the real world things
get way more complicated this is a quote
from
stuart russell who sort of wrote the
book on aia when a system is optimizing
a function of n variables where the
objective depends on a subset of size k
which is less than n
it will often set the remaining
unconstrained variables to extreme
values
if one of those unconstrained variables
is something that we care about the
solution found may be highly undesirable
in the real world we have a very large
number of variables and so
we're talking about we're talking about
very large
values for n here so let's say you've
got your robot
and you've given it a gold which you
think is very simple you want it to get
you a cup of tea
so you've managed to specify what a cup
of tea is and that you want one to be
on the desk in front of you so far so
good
but suppose there is a there's a
processing vars on a narrow
stand sort of in front of where the
kitchen is so the robot
immediately plows into the vars and
destroys it on its way to make you a cup
of tea because
you only gave it one variable to keep
track of in the goal
which is the t it doesn't care about the
vars you never told it to care about the
vars
it destroys the vast this is a problem
um
so okay now you can you know shut it
down modify it and say
okay give me a cup of tea but also don't
knock over the vars
but then there will be a third thing
there is always another thing
because when when you're making
decisions in the real world
you're always making trade-offs you're
always
taking various things that you value and
deciding how much
of one you're willing to trade for how
much of another you know i could do this
quicker
but it increases the risk of me making a
mistake or i
could do this cheaper but it won't be as
reliable
i could do this faster but it'll be more
expensive you're always trading these
things off against one another
and so an agent like this which only
cares about a limited subset of the
variables in the system
will be willing to trade off arbitrarily
large amounts
of any of the variables that aren't part
of its goal for arbitrarily tiny
increases
in any of the things which are in its
goal so it will happily
i let's say now for example now it
values the vars
uh and those are the only things that it
values it might reason something like
okay there's a human in the environment
the human moves around the human
may accidentally knock over the vars and
i care about the vars so i have to kill
the human
right and this is totally ridiculous but
if you didn't tell it that you value
being alive it doesn't care and anything
that it doesn't value
is going to be lost if you manage to
come up with if you have a sufficiently
powerful agent
and you manage to come up with a really
good objective function which
covers the top 20 things that humans
value
the 21st thing that humans value is
probably gone forever
because the smarter the more powerful
the agent is
the better it will be at figuring out
ways to make these trade-offs
to gain a millionth of a percent better
at one thing
while sacrificing everything of some
other variable
so this is a problem but actually that
scenario i gave was unrealistic in
many ways but but one important way that
it was unrealistic
is that i had i had the system go wrong
and then you just turn it off
and fix it but in fact if you're
if the thing has a goal of getting you a
cup of tea this is not like a chess ai
where you can just turn it off because
it has no concept of itself or
being turned off its
world model contains you it contains
itself it contains the possibility of
being turned off and it's fully aware
that if you turn it off
because it knocked over the vars it
won't be able to get you any tea which
is the only thing it cares about
so it's not going to just let you turn
it off it will fight you
or if it's slightly smarter it will
deceive you so that you believe it's
working correctly
so that you don't want to change it
until it's in a position
where you can't turn it off and then it
will go after its actual objective
so so this is a problem
and the thing is this is this is a
convergent instrumental goal which means
it sort of doesn't matter what the goal
is it doesn't matter what your goal is
as an agent
if you're destroyed you can't achieve
that goal so it sort of almost doesn't
matter what goal we give it there is
only a very tiny fraction of possible
goals
that will involve it actually allowing
itself to be turned off and modified
and that's quite complicated um
there are some other convergent
instrumental goals so we had
self-preservation goal preservation
resource acquisition is the kind of
thing we can expect these kinds of
systems to do
most plans you can do them better if you
have more resources
whether that's money computational
resources just
free energy matter whatever
the other one is self-improvement
whatever you're trying to do
you can probably do it better if you're
smarter and ai systems potentially have
the capacity to improve themselves
either just by
acquiring more hardware to run on or
changing
you know improving their uh their
software to run faster or better or so
on
so there's a whole bunch of behaviors
which
uh intelligent systems intelligent
agents
generally intelligent agents we would
expect them to do
by default and that's really
my core point artificial general
intelligence is dangerous by default
it's much much easier to build these
kinds of agents
which try to do ridiculous things and
trick you
and try to deceive you or will fight you
when you try to turn them off or modify
them
on the way to doing some ridiculous
thing which you don't want
uh much easier to build that kind of
agent than
it is to build something which actually
reliably does what you want it to do
and that's why we have a problem because
we have
45 to 120 years to figure out
how to do it safely which is a much
harder problem and
we may only get one shot it's entirely
possible that the first
true artificial general intelligence
will manage to successfully achieve
whatever its stupid goal is
and that could be truly a disaster on a
global scale
so we have to we have to beat this
challenge
on hard mode before anyone beats it on
easy mode
so are we screwed
no we're only probably screwed
um there are things we can do
safe general artificial intelligence is
totally possible
it's just a very difficult technical
challenge
and there are people working very hard
on it right now trying to solve
a whole range of difficult technical
challenges
so that we can figure out how to do this
safely
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
you may have noticed in the intro in
this outro that the image quality has
improved since the last video
that's largely thanks to my excellent
patrons thank you to all of these people
here for helping me to get this new
camera in this video i'm especially
thanking james pets who's been hanging
out with us on the discord server
helping answer questions from the
youtube comments and so on and actually
that last video about mesa optimizers
has had a lot of really good questions
so the next video will be answering some
of those
that's coming up soon so thanks again to
james and to all my patrons
to everyone who asked questions and to
you for watching
i'll see you next time
you